effectivement c'est un décor très très
futuriste que nous montre jean cazenave
en ce moment même notre réalisateur
c'est le décor de la cité des sciences
et de l'industrie
alors ne vous y trompez pas en fait
cette cité des sciences et de
l'industrie est aussi contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait peut-être imaginer c'est
aussi un haut lieu de culture derrière
moi par exemple derrière cet ascenseur
il y à une médiathèque et dans cette
médiathèque il ya beaucoup de choses
pourraient pas tout vous décrire mais il
ya aussi beaucoup beaucoup de livres
alors qui est rassemblée ici pour cette
finale
j'appuie sur le deuxième étage parce
qu'il faut que descendre jusqu'en bas
sinon on n'y arrivera pas alors qu'ils
rassemblaient ici pour cette deuxième
finale du championnat de france
d'apporter d'apostrophés organique d'à
d'orthographe pardon j'y arriverai je
suis troublé par l'ascenseur qui ne
descendent pas organisé avec nos
confrères du magazine lire eh bien il ya
sans cesse candidats les cent seize
finalistes les 116 qui ont réussi
d'abord les tests éliminatoires puis les
demi finales organisées à l'aide du
crédit agricole bien sûr vous le savez
puis à diffuser en direct sur fr3
aujourd'hui la finale pour cis candidats
divisés en trois catégories vous allez
le voir c'est en direct sur antenne 2
voilà donc pour les candidats qui sont
là et puis avec tous ces candidats
nous allons retrouver aussi un certain
nombre de personnalités les
personnalités elles sont ici elles sont
dans la médiathèque voyez alors ya
beaucoup de livres c'est vrai je vous ai
pas menti
c'est les personnalités qui ont pris le
risque de venir tester leur orthographe
mais peut-être aussi de venir tester
leur amour propre alors il ya beaucoup
de gens connus il y à des scientifiques
comme joël de rosnay
vous allez voir on a un peu mélangé tout
le monde il ya beaucoup d'écrivains bien
sûr c'est la moindre des choses
yves berger par exemple mais il y a
aussi des gens de
domaine plus divers par exemple la
cuisine alain sein de reims il y à aussi
daniel mesguich lui bien sûr c'est le
comédien et le mettait en scène que vous
connaissez bien
il ya des gens de la télé que vous
connaissez bien aussi parce que par
exemple bertrand renard vous le
connaissez c'est pas la peine de le
présenter avec côté de lui il ya jean
philippe chauveau jean philippe chauveau
vous savez c'est le champion des
chiffres et des lettres alors on va voir
s'il fait aussi bien en orthographe
il y a donc je vous le disais beaucoup
d'écrivains s'en va y revenir souvent
suzanne rouge crois qu'elle est très
très forte est l'une des favorites parmi
les personnalités et un danseur à côté
d'elle michael denard bravo d'avoir pris
le risque
bravo alors je continue au milieu des
personnalités de ce côté-ci ya beaucoup
de gens de la télé vous allez voir
regarder ma consoeur anne sinclair de
tf1 ivan levaï d' europe 1 france henri
de virieu paul lefebvre tient je vois
aussi un réalisateur d' apostrophes
c'est jean-luc léridon bonjour jean luc
lui il fait la dictée aujourd'hui robert
chapatte tient et où l'ami robert entre
deux écrivains deux académiciens m jean
dutourd et félicien marceau
alors voilà robert vous êtes en bonne
compagnie et puis je vais encore de ce
côté là il ya encore beaucoup d'autres
invités qui avaient renié antoine de
gaudemar et puis il ya aussi maurice
lévy qui est au fond l'homme du la cité
des sciences et de l'industrie alors
merci de nous accueillir monsieur le
président voilà et puisque nous parlons
de vedettes et bien il ya aussi un
maître d'école tient jouer à bernard
pivot là c'est lui qui va lire la dictée
et puis ici il ya tous les candidats
alors je vais pas tous voulaient
présenter ce serait un petit peu
compliqué je vous en présenter un quand
même parce que
voilà c'est lui qui est ici il s'appelle
georges sauvage bonjour monsieur sauvage
je vous présente parce que vous êtes le
seul qui dans les demi finales il faut
le dire n'a fait aucune faute dans la
dictée alors moi je veux juste vous
poser une petite question est ce que
vous vous mettez à la place en ce moment
de vos élèves qui quand vouloir faire
faire une interrogation écrite par m oui
j'ai sûrement de rattraper aujourd'hui
sûrement faire quelques fautes
aujourd'hui vous avez les mains moites
ça va faire plaisir du côté du mans bien
j'interroge pas tout le monde parce
qu'on en finirait pas ils sont sans
cesse que je peux vous dire c'est qu'ils
sont divisés en trois catégories
une catégorie juniors il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui ont répondu aux questions aux
tests qui ont passé avec succès les demi
finales il y a aussi une catégorie
senior amateur et puis une catégorie
seniors professionnels ça les seniors
professionnels ce sont ceux qui sont
professeurs de lettres par exemple ou
correcteurs ou spécialistes en tout cas
alors voilà donc pour la présentation
je pense que tout le monde est prêt
maintenant j'ai juste à vous rappeler
simplement que tout à l'heure sur
antenne 2 en direct il y aura la
correction de la dictée à 19h 19h05 je
crois qui ensuite la remise des prix
avec de très très beaux prix pour les
gagnants des voyages très lointains
notamment alors est ce que tout le monde
est prêt bernard je pense que c'est à
vous maintenant
eh bien merci merci hervé alors je
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir je vous
rappelle d'abord les règles du jeu le
jeu dictent la ponctuation il n'y aura
donc deux fautes ni de ponctuation ni de
majuscules je fais toutes les liaisons
et enfin jeu là je m'adresse surtout aux
candidats et aux personnalités je vous
invite à écrire très clairement de telle
sorte que les correcteurs puisse
distinguer les veaux accent grave de
vaud accent aigu l'accent aigu
et guigou j'ai dit que je faisais toutes
les liaisons à la celle là oui je
commence bien les accents aigus alors je
vais d'abord lire le texte de la dictée
bien entendu comme à l'école primaire
c'est à dire on fait le en continu et
puis après la dictée proprement dit et
puis je relirai le texte après vous
aurez 5 minutes de réflexion et ensuite
on ramassera les copies donc je vais
commencer par le texte en continu ce
texte hervé claude le disais tout à
l'heure il est de micheline seulement il
a été revu alors vraiment dans tous les
détails dans tous les recoins par des
correcteurs professionnels alors
allons-y candidats vous êtes prêts les
personnalités sont prêtes les
téléspectateurs et téléspectatrices sont
prêts alors allons-y 3 fureteur insolite
en achetant des biens à des ayants droit
sans le sou cet antiquaire s'était
constitué un fonds hétéroclite hors pair
en navette ont vu défiler à la queue leu
leu des dilettantes et des marchands de
tout acabit
fasciné par son bric-à-brac voir son
capharnaüm pêle-mêle se trouvaient
rassemblées là des crédences des
bonheurs du jour des mets berrichonne
des poêlons des cauchemars et même des
astragale abîmé qu'elle s'était laissé
fourguer par des maîtres chanteurs
jusque là s'étaient succédé des clients
si extravagant qu'elle était à cent
lieues de penser qu'on pût les pattes et
encore
un jour pourtant 3 m'as-tu-vu
patibulaire s'étaient introduits presque
en catimini dans sa boutique exigu et la
s'arrêtera la dictée pour les juniors et
je continue pour les seniors aussitôt le
moins bizarre avait interpellé
l'antiquaire se déclarant à la recherche
de ciel de lit rococo qu'il s'était
représenté garni de pampilles violacé
pendant ce temps ses acolytes lorgnant
d'éclat me2 défraîchi s'en était drapé
puis s'étaient déhanchées devant des
psychés santin trouvant cocasse de
mouflons borgne empaillé et trois à ibb
ou naturalisés qui cohabitaient il les
avait frénétiquement épousseter jusqu'à
ce qu'une figurine en équilibre précaire
s'écrasa sur les ex voto d'un lieu saint
rhodanien les recherches s'étant déroulé
et couci couça leurs compères s'étaient
rabattus sur deux planisphère jaunies
qu'il paya content tout ébaubi et tout
soulagé l'antiquaire regarde à
s'éloigner ce trio d'olibrius dans une
carriole tintinnabulantes point final
évidemment dans ce décor futuriste vous
attendiez à une à une dictée sur sur les
sciences et l'industrie eh bien pas du
tout par esprit de contradiction sont
allés dans la vieillerie chez les
antiquaires
alors allons-y 3 c'est le titre iii
fureteur insolite trois furent auteurs
insolite
en achetant des biens
à des ayants droit sans le sou virgules
à baiser endroit sans le sou virgules
cet antiquaire s'était constitué
cet antiquaire
s'était constitué
un faune hétéroclite hors pair points
un faune hétéroclite hors pair points en
navette ont vu défiler virgule en
navette ont vu défiler virgule à la
queue leu leu virgule à la queue leu leu
virgule des dilettantes et des marchands
de tout acabit
des dilettantes et des marchands de tout
acabit
fasciné par son bric-à-brac virgules
[Musique]
fasciné par son bric-à-brac virgule voir
son capharnaüm point d'exclamation
voir son capharnaüm point d'exclamation
pêle-mêle se trouvaient rassemblées là
des crédences virgules
des crédences via l'une des bonnes
heures du jour virgule des bonheurs du
jour
virgule des mets berrichonne virgules
des mets berrichonne virgules
des poêlons virgule déco comme un
virgule des poêlons virgules
déco comme un art virgules
et même des astragale abîmé mêmes
des astragale abîmée
qu'elle s'était
l'essai fourguer par des maîtres
chanteurs point à la ligne
quel
c'était l'essai fourguer par des maîtres
chanteurs
point à la ligne
jusque là s'étaient succédé
[Musique]
des clients si extravagant
des clients si extravagant qu'elle était
à cent lieues de penser
qu'elle était à cent lieues de penser
qu'ont pu les pattes et encore point
d'exclamation
d'exclamation un jour virgule pourtant
virgule un jour virgules pourtant
virgule 3 m'as-tu-vu patibulaire 3
m'as-tu-vu patibulaire
s'étaient introduits presque en catimini
dans sa boutique exigu 3 point à la
ligne
hélas la dictée s'arrête pour les
juniors maintenant je continue pour les
seigneurs aussitôt virgule le moins
bizarre aussitôt virgule le moins
bizarre avait interpellé l'antiquaire
virgule avait interpellé l'antiquaire
virgules
se déclarant à la recherche se déclarant
à la recherche
de ciel de lit rococo de ciel de lit
rococo qu'il s'était représenté qu'il
s'était représenté garni de pampilles
violacé trois points garni de pampilles
violacé trois points pendant ce temps
virgule ses acolytes virgules pendant ce
temps virgule ses acolytes virgule
s'étaient déhanchées
ah non pardon pardon je me trompe
excusez moi je redonne chose au déni
pendant ce temps virgule ses acolytes
virgules lorgnant d'éclat me2 défraîchi
répète pendant ce temps virgule ses
acolytes virgules lorgnant d'éclat mine
défraîchie virgules lorgnant des
chlamydiae défraîchi virgule s'en était
drapé virgules c'en était drapé virgules
puis s'étaient déhanchées
devant des psychés sentent un point
devant
des six chez
santin points trouvant cocasse de
mouflons borgne empaillés trouvant
cocasse de mouflons borgne empaillé et 3
hibou naturalisés je répète pour
monsieur du tour trouvant que casse de
mouflons borgne empaillé et 3 hibou
naturalisés qui cohabitaient virgules
qui cohabitaient virgules il les avait
frénétiquement t pousse t il les avait
frénétiquement épousseter jusqu'à ce
qu'une figurine jusqu'à ce qu'une
figurine en équilibre précaire en
équilibre précaire s'écrasa sur les ex
voto s'écrasa sur les ex voto
d'un lieu saint rhodaniens pointent à la
ligne d'un lieu saint rhodanien
point à la ligne les recherches s'étant
déroulés couci couça virgules les
recherches s'étant déroulé
couci couça virgule leurs compères
s'étaient rabattus leurs compères
s'étaient rabattus sur deux planisphère
jaunies sur deux planisphère jaunies
qu'il paya content point à la ligne
tout ébaubi et tout soulagé virgule tout
ébaubi
et tout soulagé virgules l'antiquaire
regarde à s'éloigner ce trio d'olibrius
l'antiquaire regarde à s'éloigner
ce trio de l'hybride us dans une
carriole tintinnabulantes point final
dans une carriole tintinnabulantes point
final
mesdames et messieurs je vais relire
cette dictée et ensuite vous aurez 5
minutes pour réfléchir pour changer on
modifier ou peut-être pour ne pas
changer trois fureteur insolite en
achetant des biens
à des ayants droit sans le sou virgules
cet antiquaire s'était constitué un
fonds hétéroclite hors pair points en
navette ont vu défiler virgule à la
queue leu leu virgule des dilettantes et
des marchands de tout acabit
[Musique]
fasciné par son bric-à-brac virgule voir
son capharnaüm point d'exclamation
pêle-mêle se trouvaient rassemblées là
des crédences virgule des bonheurs du
jour virgule des mets berrichonne
virgule des poêlons virgule des coq marc
virgule et même des astragale abîmé
qu'elle s'était laissé fourguer par des
maîtres chanteurs pointe à la ligne
jusque là s'étaient succédé des clients
si extravagant qu'elle était à cent
lieues de penser qu'on pût les pattes et
encore pour l'estimation un jour virgule
pourtant virgule 3 m'as-tu-vu
patibulaire s'étaient introduits presque
en catimini dans sa boutique exigu 3
point à la ligne
aussitôt virgule le moins bizarre avait
interpellé l'antiquaire virgule se
déclarant à la recherche de ciel de lit
rococo qu'il s'était représenté garni de
pampilles violacé trois points pendant
ce temps virgule ses acolytes virgules
lorgnant d'éclat me2 défraîchi virgule
s'en était drapé virgule puis s'étaient
déhanchées devant des psychés 101 points
trouvant que casse de mouflons borgne
empaillé et 3 hibou naturalisés
qui cohabitaient virgules il les avait
frénétiquement épousseter jusqu'à ce
qu'une figurine en équilibre précaire
s'écrasa sur les ex voto d'un lieu saint
rhodanien point à la ligne
les recherches s'étant déroulé couci
couça virgule leurs compères s'étaient
rabattus sur deux planisphère jaunies
qu'il paya content point à la ligne
tout ébaubi et tout soulagé l'antiquaire
regarde à s'éloigner ce trio de lits
brioude dans une carriole
tintinnabulantes point final et je vous
signale que dans la première ligne
j'ai pas fait la lésion mais elle va de
soi c'est en achetant des biens za des
ayants droit je l'ait pas fait l'âme en
face à va de soi voilà hervé c'est à
vous l'antenne assez rapidement à nos
amis des sports jeux même tout de même
m'approcher de des personnalités
notamment je voudrais juste demandé à
jean dutourd par exemple comment il a
trouvé cette dictée je n'ai pas trouvé
très difficile
simplement j'ai une des petites
difficultés avec des tirés par exemple
m'as-tu-vu ex voto je me rappelais plus
il y avait vraiment des tirs et aya les
protestations dans la vie je ne donne
aucune espèce d'indication je ne sais
pas s'il y avait des tirs est l'avis de
robert chapatte
moi j'ai eu des problèmes à peu près à
chaque ligne je pense m'en être sorti
convenablement
l'ennui c'est que d'avoir un voisin
comme jean dutourd on ne peut pas copier
pourquoi il cache sa copine oh la la il
la cache avec beaucoup de soin bien
merci à tous il va falloir prendre
l'antenne tout de suite alors merci je
vous rappelle simplement quand même les
deux rendez vous le prochain rendez vous
c'est à 19h05 c'est sur antenne 2
restait donc avec nous car à 19h05
correction de la dictée et puis bien sûr
remise des prix avec tous les candidats
tous les candidats qui seront bien sûr
récompensés à tout à l'heure donc
[Musique]
à
bonsoir bienvenue de nouveau à la cité
des sciences et de l'industrie bienvenue
pour la dernière phase de cette finale
86 des championnats de france
d'orthographe
cette dernière phase très simple elle va
se dérouler en deux temps d'abord il y
aura la correction de la dictée et puis
ensuite il y aura la remise des prix
vous verrez ils sont très beaux et il y
en aura pour tout le monde alors en deux
temps donc d'abord la sanction ensuite
les lauriers alors tout de suite tout de
suite la correction de la dictée bernard
pivot
micheline seulement qui est la linguiste
qui a concocté cette dictée diabolique
et puis deux des personnalités qui ont
concouru et qui ma foi sont pas mal
débrouillé anne sinclair notre consoeur
de tf1 et l'écrivain et éditeur yves
berger alors voilà on va commencer
on va revoir ce texte de dictée et
évidemment les uns les autres pour en
faire des commentaires 3 fureteur
insolite en achetant des biens à des
ayants droit
mais chez nous le trait d'union ayants
droit comme ayants cause prennent tu as
au premier composé est pas au second
alors des ayants droit sans le sou à
nous avait une faute à l'endroit moyens
sont bons sans le sou cet antiquaire
c'était un féminin tout simplement
c'est le sens qu'il indiqué par la suite
puisque on s'apercevait que c'était une
femme
cet antiquaire s'était constitué un
fonds ont le ds alors oui attention ne
pas confondre avec un fond fo ndé qui
pouvaient eni et ne pas confondre non
plus avec les fonts baptismaux et fo
était alors un faune hétéroclite hors
pair bon père il faut connaître hors
pair alors allons-y en navette ont vu
défiler à la queue leu leu alors à si
vous voulez bien laisser le texte s'il
vous plaît la queue leu leu
alors là que le bât blesse et l'ancienne
forme du loup l e u
et de plus il ne fallait pas mettre de
trait d'union des dilettantes n'est pas
évident haute et yves berger
dans des bons et des marchands de tout
acabit fasciné par son bric-à-brac
c'est un nom masculin invariable et qui
prenait 2 trait d'union voir alors voir
il faut un bien sûr lorsque la celle
adverbe ce n'est pas du tout le 100 m
capharnaüm bon ben je compte sur moi
c'est connu quand même le capharnaüm
mais il le tréma sur lui c'était une
double faute bien entendu nous
continuons avec le texte s'il vous plaît
pêle-mêle se trouvait ou plurielle
rassemblés là des crédences alors des
crédences y en avait une à côté là à ma
gauche là avec 15 1 e crédence voilà
c'est ça des bonheurs du jour alors ça
c'est un bonheur du jour voilà avec des
petits tiroirs
et puis il y avait aussi des mets
berrichonne ça c'est une mais joujou pas
qu'elle soit berrichonne m'enfin c'est
une mais quand même c'est comme un
pétrin et puis il y avait des poils on
vous avez un poêlon 6 sur la mer et des
coques marque mot coquemar qui était
déjà dans la dictée l'année dernière
c'est un moyen violence et dernière fois
de ma vie que je vois un coq marc mes
chers à vis des voix voilà bah c'était
un cauchemar de votre grand-mère
utiliser un coq marc sans aucun doute
voilà donc des côtes alors il faut
revenir sur ce texte et pau lors du jour
bon alors le rsa bonheur bien sûr les
deux trades union et un variabilité de
jours des mets berrichonne mais il faut
savoir maillot s le savoir l'écrire oui
alors poêlon il faut remarquer que seul
un poil l'appareil de chauffage prend ou
ne prend pas le traitement des coquemar
hébergé mme caunesil à moi je pensais
qu'ils iraient temps des aussi mais
simplement je jean cazenave s'ils
voulaient nous laisser davantage le
texte s'il vous plaît merci et même des
astragale alors les asie mais voilà les
astragale sont des moulures
mais quel que soit le sens c'est un nom
du masculin oui donc abîmé et s alors il
faut se rappeler le célèbre ver de
boileau ce ne sont que festons ce ne
sont castrats galles et puis le titre
d'un livre c'est qu'avec le même genre
c'est la pagaille c'est le sait le
laisse d'un autre c'est l'os du coup de
pied
quel site alice est fournie par des
maîtres chanteurs alors de ces faux
billets pour les maîtres chanteurs alors
laissé fourguer alors là c'est la règle
des participes passés des verbes
pronominaux après s'être laissé le verbe
était là l'infinitif donc un variabilité
de l'essai puisque le sujet ne faisait
pas l'action et fourguer par des maîtres
chanteurs il n'y a donc pas de trait
d'union entre maître et chanteur le
titre s et pour souligner qu'il pouvait
y avoir une faute jusque là avec un
trait d'union s'étaient succédé ben on
voit ça c'est la règle du participe
passé du verbe pronominaux et sita n'a
varié abcès mariable des clients si
extravagant qu'elle était à cent lieues
de penser qu'on pût conclu les patrons
corps alors c'est un subjonctif il
fallait pas se tromper
voilà alors ensuite je vous en prie le
texte un jour pourtant 3 m'as-tu-vu bon
ben vous avec des traits d'union je
crois que vous passez savall toit est
invariable ya bien entendu patibulaire
s'étaient introduits presque en catimini
alors presque ne prend jamais d'
apostrophes sauf dans presqu'île en
catimini dans sa boutique exigu très mal
sur le e bien sûr hélas arrêtait la
dictée des juniors mais nous allons
continuer avec les seigneurs aussitôt le
moins bizarre avait interpellé la
beaucoup de gens ont fait la faute il
faut 2 elle a interpellé
et oui l'antiquaire se déclarant à la
recherche de ciel de l'iroko koala ciel
de lit surtout pas de trait d'union
accord de ciel et rococo invariable
violente en est un c'est à chaque fois
bien entendu bien entendu vous l'auriez
fait non non non je répète beaucoup de
fois j'aurais fait plus de dix fautes
mais rococo non jeu s'adresse d'un
variable opus éléments qui me plaît si
alors coco qu'il s'était représenté
garni alors loin pampilles violacé ans
qu'il s'était représenté le participe
passé s'accordent avec q q apostrophe
masculin pluriel et garni c'est aussi ce
sont aussi les ciel de lit qui sont
garnis dont pièce alors de papy de
pampilles violacé berger vous
amy féminin alors la voyez pas ce qu'on
confond avec pampres et bien entendu
mais d'ailleurs j'avais pensé de choc
mais je me suis dit si ton penchant
naturel va vers le féminin sais que je
dois être masculin jamie pompéi et
revenons texte pendant ce temps ses
acolytes lorgnant d'éclat mid défraîchi
alors des coups c'est un petit costume
et manteaux courts et fendus agrafées
sur l'épaule d'éclat mid défraîchi va
évidemment faire les connaître
l'orthographe de ce mot un peu compliqué
défraîchi et urgent il son genre c'en
était drapé alors ça c'est un peu
curieux gras ps alors ils se sont ils se
sont drapés dès que tu es apostrophe qui
est mis pour clame id donc draper est ce
ça c'est une d'une perversité dans le
française puis s'étaient déhanchées et s
devant des psychés sans tain et là c'est
le teint de la glace bien sûr un gros
vent cocasse 2000 on a beaucoup aux
momies des f2 et quand je les aurais
certainement mis deux heures deux
mouvements borgne empaillé et 3i booba
hibou à l'origine il bouge tout pour
xterra prennent tous un mix je crois que
c'était un cadeau c'était un clin d'oeil
à l'école primaire et trois hibou
naturalisés qui cohabitaient il les
avait frénétiquement d'épousseter alors
insulté un agent s'était à ce qu'une
figurine ça c'est un objet de en terre
cuite à 9 heures si un objet et il
fallait l'écrire très très simplement il
ne pas chercher de difficultés oui le
piège c'est effectivement j'ai été tenté
par le ph y mais je suis revenu à figer
eu en pensant qu'il aime ça avoue berger
aussi par les banques
bon en équilibre précaire s'écrasa alors
là imparfait du subjonctif sur les ex
voto exo taux variable et trait d'union
trait d'union d'un lieu saint rhodanien
alors trait d'union entre lieux saints
oui et puis rhodanien ça vient de re dan
huss l'ancien nom du rhône et il n'y
avait qu'un n
les recherches s'étant déroulés couci
couça ou inattention dit en tension avec
la cédille oui mais là c'est dit
le ca a oui bon l'heure n'est pas devant
l'une seddik seulement leurs compères
s'étaient rabattus sur deux planisphère
jauni attention au genre de planisphère
un planisphère jaunies dont qui s
c'était aussi un autre piège qu'il paya
content ça paye est content content et
adverbe ici est invariable tout ébaubi
là il s'agit de l'antiquaire alors tout
ébaubi tout devant achever ou une
voyelle ne prend pas de bien sûr c'était
un piège série alors lieu devant tout
soulagé il y à une consonne il y avait
un moi j'ai mis deux aux deux tout
inquiet mais c'était le piège là tout
ébaubi et tout soulagé l'antiquaire
regarde à s'éloigner ce trio d'olibrius
cette amo finalement assez courant mais
on ne sait pas lire et beaucoup de gens
y mettent 1 h
oui yves non non non et non et oui je
connaissais le mot bombe est parfait
dans une carriole 2 r oui deux r1
carriole il n'ya que chariot dans cette
famille qui ne prend qu'un nt1 tina plus
lente à l'aller 2 n à la 7è piège
terrible c'est beaucoup n'ai jamais
tenté mais ça vient d'un mot latin qui
prenait lui-même de zen très bien et
bien voilà
c'était une fois une dictée disons le
très difficile et je répète ce que j'ai
dit dans le journal de 13h à savoir que
tous ceux qui ont fait moins de dix
fautes sont des cracks et je dirais que
ceux qui ont fait entre 10 et 20 fautes
c'est pas mal non plus parce que vous
savez parmi les personnalités il y en a
beaucoup qui ont fait plus de 20 fautes
et même je crois parmi des finalistes il
y en a qui ont voisiné les les vins faut
donc bravo à tous ceux qui ont fait
moins de vie de 10 fautes ils sont
extraordinaires hervé claude c'est à
vous et bien bernard effectivement
maintenant chacun sait chacun sait son
nombre de fautes chacun peut penser
aussi ses blessures d'amour propre à
leurs parents de bernard va nous
rejoindre je vous rappelle que les
champions de france il va y en avoir
trois cette année puisqu'il y avait
trois séries plus une
les personnalités alors il y aura donc
trois champions de france les lauréats
vont être récompensés et ce sont les pdg
des différentes sociétés qui ont
organisé ce championnat qui vont
remettre les prix alors je vous les
présente pour les juniors ce sera
bernard aux bergers du crédit agricole
pour les seniors amateurs ce sera janine
langlois glandier pdg de fr3 et puis
pour les seniors professionnels ce sera
jean drucker pdg d'antenne 2 alors
bernard même le temps est venu
maintenant ça y est de donner les
résultats et on va commencer je pense
par les juniors alors seul viendront
simplement les trois premiers alors je
signale que par exemple le cinquième
c'est fabien rosa de dijon 4 fautes et
demi le quatrième place il y à un suisse
il s'appelle olivier rapin il a fait
quatre fautes
oui je crois qu'à cette occasion bernard
lui il est bon de signaler qu'il y avait
dans cette finale 3 belge et trois
suisses il y avait des candidats vous le
savez les 116 qui venaient de toute la
france mais il y avait aussi nos habits
belle nos amis belges et nos amis
suisses et on les remercie tout
particulièrement voilà alors 3e et elle
peut venir sur le sur l'ordre là parmi
nous il s'agit de marianne bernard de
limoges 18 ans 4 fautes
[Applaudissements]
alors deuxième place c'est un
marseillais jean-françois groff 18 ans
trois fautes et demi
et enfin à la première place donc
championne junior de france
d'orthographe
une lilloise perez relisez bronsky 19
ans sait
alors
[Applaudissements]
ils thérèse bravo d'abord je crois que
c'est une première chose qu'on peut vous
dire quel âge avez-vous 18 ans alors
vous vous êtes d'où des fous calais lens
est-ce que vous avez déjà été distingué
en orthographe
ben à l'école ça a été que j'avais
toujours des bons résultats toujours la
première cause des cartographes quand tu
viens sur des très bons résultats depuis
distingué en demi finale à cause de quoi
vous vient ce goût particulier pour
l'orthographe c'est comme ça depuis
j'étais petit j'aimais bien c'était la
matière que je préférais à l'école de
l'orthographe et là vous avez préparé un
petit peu la finale particulièrement non
[Musique]
comment comment on se prépare ça
m'intrigue pas mal de gens j'ai ressorti
des faits bouquin tout ça surtout les
bouquins de primaires tout ça ça me
rappelait un peu avant et j'ai acheté
des nouveaux jets j'ai fait attention à
tout ce qu'on disait autour de moi j'ai
tout eu les mots qui sonnait un peu
bizarre bons jeux les jeux les noter
puis je regardais chez moi tout ça bravo
thérèse monsieur bergé va vous remettre
votre prix bravo un prix qui est aussi
un voyage
[Applaudissements]
faut dire que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thérèse thérèse gagne un séjour pour
deux personnes de huit jours à l'île
maurice
et puis jean-françois lui gagne un
séjour pour deux personnes aux antilles
et puis bien entendu comme vous êtes les
premiers vous pourrez choisir parmi
toutes les encyclopédies et tous les
dictionnaires c'est vous qui choisirez
mais tous les finalistes auront droit à
l'un de ses ouvrages
alors la deuxième catégorie maintenant
bernard c'est les seniors amateurs
seniors amateurs et c'est madame le blog
langlois glandier pardon qui va remettre
les prix alors je bon disons que là le
dixième place geneviève la vôtre
toulouse 4 fautes et demie 9e place
francis lance de paris quatre fautes
gilles lambert de versailles 4 fautes
jean-pierre de cours ou de versailles
profond et demi 6e
didier lancina de bordeaux 3 fautes 5e
jeancolas de mots trois fautes quatrième
denise hersant de bordeaux 3 fautes 3e 1
belge rené louis trépan de fonds et demi
avec second avec deux fautes
jean-yves pélisson de lyon
et enfin avec une faute et demi champion
de france 1986 amateur seniors amateurs
d'orthographe
c'est un marseillais pierre chiche
mais ce 6e bravo encore
alors quel est votre profession ben je
suis retraité maintenant de 15
ingénieurs chimistes aux charbonnages de
france et dans la sourire des
charbonnages à quoi sert l'orthographe
dans la semi ben là c'est trop grave sur
dans toute façon j'ai toujours aimé
leurs taux grave toujours la langue
française est bon ça m'a toujours
beaucoup intéressé donc je peux pas dire
ça mais spécialement servi dans la
chimie si ça m'a servi beaucoup à
corriger les fautes d'orthographes de
tous ceux qui étaient autour de moi vous
aviez déjà été distingué en orthographe
non l'année dernière je venais j'étais
en train de déménager j'avais fait ça
trop vite et j'avais pas pu aller
jusqu'au bout bravo manger baby
autrefois il édicte et oui quand j'étais
jeune en primaire je vais toujours zéro
faute aux dictées ça nous a pas incités
à vous orienter vers des matières
littéraires mais dont vous voyez
ben non merci et bravo
[Applaudissements]
seniors professionnels alors là leurs
résultats sont évidemment à s'extraire
puisque le la 10e arlette rivière de
lyon n'a fait que trois fautes et demi
ensuite patrick bigot le lille 3 fautes
patrick tisseau de grenoble 3 fautes
michel balland beauce beauchemin lille 3
fautes nous arrivons la 6e une faute et
demi seulement paulette père aimant de
dijon égalité avec d'ile-de-france ville
de versailles une faute et demie rené
bouquet de nice une faute et demi et
puis voici les trois lauréats un
toulousain avec une faute ennemis andré
zarni
[Applaudissements]
à la seconde place jean labour ya de
paris avec une faute
[ __ ]
et enfin champion de france 1986
d'orthographe dans la catégorie seniors
professionnels
eh bien ça n'est pas une surprise
c'était le favori c'était le manceau qui
n'avait commis aucune faute d'un an et
demi finale et qui l'a emporté à la
finale avec une faute mais il était à
égalité avec jean laborde ya ils ont été
départagés dans les tests qui ont été
faits ensuite je le dis haut pour les
téléspectateurs après la dictée il a été
départagé à la deuxième phrase deuxième
phrase qu'elles n'ont commis aucune
faute à la première phrase mais jean la
bouriane a commis 3 dans la deuxième
phrase et georges sauvage n'a commis
qu'une donc avec une faute à la dictée
champion de france georges sauvage du
mans
alors georges sauvage voyez j'ai bien
fait de vous interroger tout à l'heure
je voudrais que vous étiez favorite ça
n'a pas manqué oui bah c'est un peu une
surprise quand même je m'attendais pas à
faire deux fois
bonne performance à quoi vous vous
attendiez après avoir fait la dictée est
dans le peloton de tête quand même je ne
voyais aucune faute les celle que vous
avez fait réellement c'était quoi
bonheur du jour je lai je les ai mis
tout bêtement à variable ah oui donc il
fallait mettre à aimer invariable vous
n'avez pas mis dès sa bonne heure parce
que les pessimistes honneur je me mets
toujours au pluriel tête oui ben ali
[Rires]
georges sauvage vous êtes professeur de
lettres se dit tout à l'heure gt gt je
suis à la retraite maintenant quand vous
voyez vos élèves faire beaucoup de
fautes d'orthographe ça vous inspirait
quoi vous qui a été vraiment un
spécialiste
on essayait d'en faire moins jeu j'étais
là pour l'heure pour les entraîner en
faire un petit peu moins ça vous agace
et ça vous mettez en colère il ya des
enfants qui sont un peu réticents à
l'orthographe non non non mais
l'orthographe ça s'enseigne et je crois
que je me débrouillais pas trop mal
quand j'enseignais l'orthographe vous
est ce que vous êtes entraîné un petit
peu avant comment on s'entraîne tout
bêtement je me suis rendu compte que
c'était le vocabulaire qui posait des
problèmes et on a encore vu aujourd'hui
un vocabulaire de tous les jours
alors j'ai pris le petit larousse et
puis j'ai noté un certain nombre de mots
de vocabulaire et puis comme ça j'ai su
me débrouiller mais il y en avait au
moins deux ou trois je ne sais pas dans
votre dicter un démo vous ne connaissiez
pas par exemple ce intéressant régulier
puis ah oui je crois qu'effectivement
figurines ya beaucoup de gens qui
étaient surpris l'élan une fois dont qui
pendent là les pampilles je ne connais
pas ça alors vous avez créé au pif
oui exactement merci beaucoup georges
sauvage merci bien bernard il reste une
dernière catégorie on va d'abord jean
drucker voudrait
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr félicité monsieur sauvage mais
je voudrais qu'il me kill me rassure car
j'ai libération kg un instant
d'inquiétude zéro faute en demi-finale
une faute en finale c'est une faiblesse
passagère vous allez est ce qu'on
voudrait oui alors avant de avant de
passer à la suite et encore il faut
encore parler des personnalités de la
dictée des personnalités moi je voudrais
revenir un petit peu sur les premiers de
chaque catégorie et leur demander
quelles fautes ils ont fait parce qu'on
a un peu oublié de le faire je crois que
c'est très intéressant alors monsieur
chiche par exemple je ne sais pas vous
ne savez plus du tout bois peluches et
plus ils vont avoir des traits d'union à
la queue leu leu que j'ai mis ça c'est
sûr il en fallait pas paraît-il c'est ce
qui vous a semblé le plus difficile les
traits d'union les ponctuations heures
je me suis posé des questions oui parce
qu on perd je mènerai d'union st jean
mais pas hors pair oui oui par exemple
et puis le bonheur du jour j'ai hésité
effectivement que je me suis dit après
tout pourquoi se mettrait pas au pluriel
bon enfin il n'était pas sûr sur voyez
j'ai eu beau on a eu beau croire qu'on
révise ce qu'on a vu des tas de choses
entendent toujours sur des pièges quand
même là vous souvenez d'autres fautes
encore non ça me revient pas comme ça
tout de suite vous passionne reviendra
vous doutiez vous alliez gagner quand
vous avez entendu la correction ah oui
tout à fait oui oui quand j'ai vu que
j'étais pas dans les sept premières nous
soutient je suis quand même plus loin
qu'au dixième j'étais votre compte en
banque sans plus alors je m'attendais
pas du tout je me suis dit bon mais
c'est cuit pour cette fois on verra
l'année prochaine
non merci bien on va les voir maintenant
la copie woods ingénieurs du meilleur
junior là de la meilleure junior jude
est ce que vous vous souvenez les fautes
que vous avez fait à berrichon je suis
pas mis deux heures astragale j'ai cru
que c'était féminin et puis j'ai fait
deux fautes poêlon je me un tréma et
puis une autre fête d'action sa maison
c'est ça il faut tout différent tu
arrives to différentes allant venons en
maintenant à la catégorie des les
personnalités alors je vous signale que
bruno de valve qui avait gagné l'année
dernière qui était champion de france et
bien n'a fait que deux fautes
il se serait donc classé second chez les
amateurs puisqu'il était d'amateur il
serait donc classé second cette année
alors les personnalités évidemment
d'abord il faut saluer je rêve où les
applaudissent y est tous et toutes
parce que
[Applaudissements]
parce que c'était très courageux il y en
a quelques-uns qui sont venus sachant
qu'ils allaient commettre beaucoup de
fautes effectivement ils en ont commis
beaucoup puisque il ya des trente fautes
25 fautes 20 fautes donc elle a donc moi
je considère que toutes les
personnalités qui ont fait moins de 20
fautes sont quand même je trouve à
féliciter alors il y a une chose top
extraordinaire on voit que c'est un
couple vraiment très bien la sortie
puisque yvan levaï a fait 17 fautes et
eu l'élégance de laisser passer son
épouse anne sinclair
juste devant lui avec seize fautes et
demi
alors l'autre qui nous reçoit ici île
maurice lévy a commis 16 fautes et il ya
beaucoup d'ex-aequo jean-luc léridon
l'un des deux à l'un des deux
réalisateurs d' apostrophes a commis six
fautes michael denard danseur étoile de
l'opéra 16 fautes c'est quand même
formidable un félicien marceau 16 fautes
aussi et puis on a non pardon pardon non
pardon avec félicien marceau à 14 fautes
et demi avec antoine de gaudemar de
libération la romancière susan proulx et
patrick brion de fr3 qui défendait les
couleurs de fr fois qu'il a très bien
défendu avec 12 fautes et demi là on
arrive déjà la sixième place chez les
personnalités sa journaliste du figaro
hervé de saint-hilaire puis la cinquième
place avec 10 fautes et demi c'est
quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien
puisqu'il s'agit de bertrand renard qui
est aussi fort donc dans l'équipe
dans les lettres 3e ex-aequo 3e ex-aequo
un jeu un journaliste de télé cassette
michel fontaine et jean dutourd de
l'académie française il n'est pas là
n'est pas là
second avec neuf fautes l'éditeur et
écrivain raymond lévy qui est là je lui
demande de venir
raymond lévy et enfin première des
personnalités avec avec sept fautes
seulement c'est un écrivain au fond
c'est normal c'est annie ernaux l'auteur
vous connaissez bien sable de la plage
mais
annuaire d'eau et europe chez elle c'est
bien dommage que nous aurions aimé la
féliciter alors raymond lévy est ce que
cette dictée vous a paru d'abord ce qui
m'épate dans les personnalités et d'être
devant deux académiciens
vous en trouverez peut-être un jour à
l'académie sûrement pas mais il faudrait
réformer les traits d'union
vous voulez plus de trait d'union il
faut réformer il faut faire une loi là
oui parce que vous avez commis
exclusivement presque exclusivement de
trait d'union
non non non non non non raymond loewy
d'un faute ça ferait dit vous savez que
c'est une demi faute pas prêt d'union
n'y avait pas 18 ans d'union
alors j'en ai fait pas mal le
il faut dire crémant lévy est l'auteur
d'un roman qui s'appelle choix de
choisel murs alors déjà c'était quand
même très compliqué hein
donc c'est normal que micheline
seulement vous est quelque peu piégé
mais en tout cas bravo et bravo aussi à
n'y a ni arnaud qui n'est pas là mais on
peut la féliciter bien
voilà il est temps maintenant de
conclure cette émission alors évidemment
comme le maître d'oeuvre de toussaint
béate france d'orthographe c'était bien
bernard pivot
c'est avoue bernard que je demande de
conclure et de remercier tout le monde
alors je voudrais évidemment remercier
tous ceux qui sont nuls à traiter tous
formidables et puis tous les
téléspectateurs qui ont participé je
sais que vous avez été des centaines de
milliers chez vous a poussé la vaisselle
et sur un coin de table à faire cette
dictée ça c'est vraiment formidable dire
c'est un jeu l'orthographe ce n'est rien
d'autre et vous avez magnifiquement
participer à ce jeu vrai remercie alors
d'abord tous les éditeurs qui nous ont
donné des encyclopédies et dictionnaires
et tout ça va conforter l'esprit de tous
les finalistes ils viendront choisir car
effectivement tous les finalistes vont
recevoir tous diront seront tous les
enjeux au five indicateurs devraient
remercier de monsieur maurice lévy qui
est le président de la cité des sciences
et de l'industrie qui nous a reçus où
est il
merci monsieur va essayer vous avez été
un autre parfait ça a été vraiment
formidable
et puis j'aimerais remercier monsieur
bernard auberger quel directeur général
du crédit agricole
sans les caisses duquel et on ne
pourrait pas organiser les demi-finales
et elles ont été magnifiquement organisé
dans les 27 villes je voudrais remercier
madame janine langlois glandier pdg de
fr3 et puis jean drucker pdg de
d'antenne 2 mon ami jean drucker qui
sont associés l'un et l'autre c'était la
première fois deux chaînes qui
s'associent fr3 y antenne 2 pour
organiser les championnats de france
d'orthographe et à cet égard il avait
reçu l'un et l'autre les félicitations
de feu
la haute autorité bonsoir à tous à
bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]